maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
alors les actualités très bien france
polémique valls duflot alors il paraît
que hollande a recadré ses ministres ça
a dû être un truc
dantesque quoi au moment où il l'a fait
dans la savane la vie s'est arrêtée
le crocodile a lâché sa proie des
papillons sont tombés en torche equateur
heureusement que la porte du conseil des
ministres étaient bien fermées parce que
sinon le mec il déplacé un fuseau
horaire que
alors on reproche à hollande son manque
d'autorité ça c'est de la perspicacité
pur pas ça se voit sur son physique tu
imagines châtré qui avec sa bouille de
hamster sous mdma
façon il ya des signes qui ne trompent
pas en ce moment il va il va extrêmement
mal il a promis de revenir tous les ans
à florange
avec son salaire il peut aller ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
mais je comprends que ce soit désolant
ce manque d'autorité enfin moi plus je
vois le manque d'autorité de hollande en
france plus je me pose des questions sur
la force de caractère du peuple malien
rome derrière toutes ces polémiques ya
une question pourquoi est ce qu'on
stigmatise les roms mais la réponse est
simple parce que ça détend
fan ça fait vachement bien que
c'est le pied face à ses sens et le
principe du bouc émissaire c'est écrit
dans la bible ben moi j'ai pas les
moyens de m'acheter un book de pousser
d'or à chaque fois que j'ai un péché
enfin je veux dire je ya le rhum il est
là
maintenant enfin laisser laissez moi au
moins ces gens là parce que je veux pas
prendre les missions en otage suis pas
là pour ça mais bon moi quand je suis
arrivé ici je détestais tout le monde
vraiment et puis l'émission bon j'ai
découvert qu'il ya des juifs qui
travaillent ici
c'est dur de le dire mais en fait il ya
des mecs sympas
alors je me dis bon va pour les juifs ok
je fais avec j'accepte alors je dis bon
et quelques arabes là je me dis tu vois
alors je fais des chroniques très anti
halal et où j'ai discuté avec certains
mais c'est des gens enfin comme nous
quoi
alors qu'est ce que je fais en plus le
pire toi il ya des noirs à l'émission là
je me dis je vais pas me faire avoir tu
te souviens que quand je suis venu ici
je rongeais rapporté à tous un petit pot
de [ __ ] enfin le truc est
en fait c'est dur est ce que c'est vrai
qu'ils n'ont pas que le rythme dans la
peau et rama
ils ont une conversation quoi
[Applaudissements]
moi je me rends compte bas que quand tu
connais un peu les gens c'est vachement
dur d'être raciste
alors moi c'est bandant plus ça a été
très dur jeudi les africains en général
c'est très très dur pour moi de
pardonner avec tout ce qu'ils nous ont
fait foi la décolonisation moi je me
suis jamais revenir
jouer au moi je n'oublie pas que si
l'algérie était toujours française le
prix du gasoil serait un peu moins élevé
et g j'ai réfléchi quoi je me suis
vraiment ouvert comme une fleur de lotus
qui
est en fait toi juifs arabes ou noirs
cdc vraiment des gens comme nous faire
rachida dati harlem désir frédéric
lefebvre ils n'ont pas la même couleur
mais ils disent les mêmes conneries
[Applaudissements]
alors alors aujourd'hui il me restait
même reste les roms
parce que des roms à la télé y en a pas
enfin par sophie à rome mais
monsieur on peut pas être tout le temps
dans l'amour on ne peut pas tout le
temps dans l'amour jésus il est mort à
33 ans le pen il est toujours là
sujets suivants horaires des magasins
alors en résumé si j'ai bien compris on
va fermer les magasins le dimanche et en
semaine on va réduire les horaires c'est
vraiment une idée géniale c'est
tellement plus agréable de faire les
courses quand tout le monde est là
je pense que l'objectif c'est de créer
des files d'attentes devant les magasins
et big up l'urss c'est
quand quand tu vois les enjeux des
municipales c'est vraiment la bougeotte
des roms le stress des mioches la
frustration des bricoleurs du dimanche
ça va être quoi le prochain sujet de
polémique le taux de sucre dans les
chouquettes c'est
moi jouer parce qu'il ya où il ya aussi
ce truc sur les rythmes scolaires alors
ccc la zumba des élèves que fo était
alors selon les médecins il faut que
quatre 4 jours et demi ça c'est le bon
rythme c'est des foutaises on va pas
assez loin l'avenir appartient aux gens
flexibles les gamins faut les habituer à
nouveautés perpétuelles été pendant une
semaine tu fais quatre jours et demi
semaine suivante cinq jours et demi je
vis est tu l'aies réveil à 4h du maître
interro surprise
[Applaudissements]
si si c'est ça
ça ça c'est du rythme ça monsieur
peillon ça c'est dur et pitchoune tulle
et déstabilise alors les gars c'est un
prochaine classe neige et boue qui les
amène au cfr jusque là
pas de façon les tailles et si les
syndicats il veut faire des rythmes
scolaires il interdit la vente des
boissons énergisantes aux jeunes
c'est vrai que les jeunes français faut
pas trop les exciter un déjà qu'ils ont
jean marc ayrault pour modèle
doucement une chose après l'autre quoi
puisque sinon une fois que l'école est
finie maintenant on promet une
récompense espèce de rsa jeunes un truc
pour les 18 25 ans bon pourquoi pas non
mais moi je me suis aussi le rsa jeunes
va s'adresser aux jeunes qui n'ont même
pas accès à un emploi d'avenir
s'agit de l'humiliation
je veux dire aux gamins non mais même un
emplois d'avenir c'est pas pour toi
en fait on va donner directement une
subvention parce que
c'est ça ou alors une ordonnance pour du
cyanure vraiment choisi quoi
ça j'ai vu que dès 2010 est un jeune sur
trois sera financé par l'état donc par
les contribuables
en fait on vient d'inventer la pension
alimentaire pour les gens qui n'ont pas
d'enfant
tu as a engagé j'arrête trésorerie le ps
déclare 60 millions de recettes c'est
pas des chiffres définitifs on attend
encore que le fils fabius 30 de
deauville
internationale à yalta sous le patronage
de poutine et la bienveillance d'obama
bayrou a rencontré borloo
en tout cas borloo qui se rapproche de
beyrouth à ccc vesoul qui dit à commercy
et bien on va [ __ ] shanghai quoi
alors terminée par une bonne nouvelle la
fiche du film diana a été retiré du pont
de l'alma
non mais ça allait trop loin c'est trop
long en même temps pour une fois qu'on
pouvait rappeler aux français que les
voitures allemand ne sont pas aussi
fiable qu'on le dit
alors
bon jeu
mais d'ici là
à 15h25 sur canal+ et bien sûr sur
canalplus.fr les corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus